on a beau être à l'abri du pire on peut
s'intéresser aux autres aussi ça peut
arriver non bonsoir
gubedos je suis très heureuse que vous
soyez encore et toujours parmi nous je
ne promets rien et j'espère que pendant
longtemps les salles seront remplis par
les femmes qui viendront vous applaudir
et pas uniquement vos conquêtes non mais
enfin nous sommes nous sommes dans la
comédie la com vous avez
sédp vous en avez séduit TS que ça j'ai
pas trop à me plaindre des femmes alors
juste avant d'avoir 60 ans vous avez
écrit ce qui me console en soufflant
bientôt ma 60e bougie c'est que dans
sexagénère il y a sexe j'étais content
quand j'ai trouvé ça j'imagine et en
faitant gu vos 74 ans qu'est-ce que vous
avez dit alors j'ai rien dit j'ai rien
dit j'ai dîné en tête à tête en Corse
dans cette Corse que vous connaissez
avec ma femme vous citez souvent
d'ailleurs une phrase d'Oscar wild avec
le temps qui passe le plus difficile
n'est pas de se sentir vieux mais de se
sentir jeune c'est vrai mais je survis
vous savez
avec insistance faire du drôle de toute
façon avec du grave ça a toujours été la
vraie formule que j'ai inventé c'est
faire du drôle avec du triste avec du
triste ça a toujours été votre formule
c'est toujours ce que vous avez fait et
maintenant encore avec votre livre donc
qui sort aux éditions Stock le jour et
on retrouve tous vos thèmes de
prédilection les femmes l'angoisse de de
la vieillesse de la maladie de la mort
la politique oui je je me suis caché
derrière un personnage et c'est un roman
mais en même temps c'est vous on vous
retrouve vous j'ai mis sur scène si
j'ose dire sur le papier j'ai mis un
personnage qui est très différent il est
plus jeune que moi il est plus blessé
que je ne le suis par la vie sa femme
l'a quitté il est juif elle est tabo
andalouse donc c'est un roman ça c'est
vrai et il y a des choses qui relèvent
totalement de de de la fiction parce que
vous n'êtes pas juif pied noir justement
non non
non mon prépuce est intacte comme vous
savez comment ça comme je
sais
commentela ben écoutez justement je ne
fais pas partie ça prendra je ne fais
pas partie de la longue liste des non vi
applaudir c'est
au j'ai su vous
résister je vous adore non vous êtes ma
sœur je le dis mais ça me touche
beaucoup que vous me disiez c'est vrai
qu'on a fait beaucoup de films ensemble
ouis vous savez j'ai plus le temps de
mentir donc quand je dis des choses en
privé ou en public je les pense ah mais
arrêtez de dire ça je n'ai plus le temps
je allé je
sel que j'aime beaucoup il avait écrit
un livre qui s'appelait le le temps qui
reste je suis dans le temps qui reste
quand même alors vous commencez votre
livre en disant aujourd'hui j'ai décidé
de me tuer quand je ne sais pas je
choisirai le jour et l'heure ça c'est le
titre de votre livre être en état de
choisir ne pas trop tarder le temps joue
contre moi à présent ne pas laisser
approcher le moins bien de l'âge et les
prévisibles humiliation quiescorte je
veux mourir par amour de la vie ouais
c'est bien debout j'ai oublié debout
debout oui c'est important deboutès
c'est important ou pourquoi ce sujet
donc vous tient à ce point à cœur ça là
j'ai pas honte de le dire il y a toute
une partie du livre qui est totalement
un reportage honnêtement c'est la mort
de ma mère tout est vrai là c'est plus
une fiction là parce que c'est ça le
livre c'est que ça se balade encore une
fois la la fiction et la réalité se
tricotent sans arrêt et de la voir à 95
ans cette femme qui était magnifique de
l'avir dans l'état où elle
était je veux pas qu'on voit comme ça et
là là pour le coup c'est de l'orgueil
c'est de c'est de la coquetterie on peut
appeler ça comme on veut mais je ne veux
pas je veux pas être dépendant je ne
veux pas je veux rester dans mon
autonomie
absolue je veux voilà et là pour le coup
je n'étais pas logique parce que j'ai
pas du tout à demander à ce qu'elle
parte j'ai pas demandé à ce qu'elle
parte j'avais envie de me la garder
parce que elle venait de découvrir
qu'elle m'aimait elle me le disait en
tout cas et vous veniez découvrir aussi
que vous l'aimiez oui d'une certaine
manière après des années de conflit
entre vous STI un peu orphelin c'est
vrai il y a pas d'âge pour ça la photo
tiens celle-ci Joe pour me faire plaisir
ma femme l'avait mise dans dans
l'appartement et je l'ai fait enlever
parce que je la supportais pas je peux
pas parce que de la voir là et moi à
côté bref mais d'ailleurs c'est un
passage de votre livre qui est émouvant
et comme toujours avec une pointe
d'humour vous racontez que le soir vous
êtes rendu à son chevet alors qu'elle
était très malade au moment de quitter
la pièce sur la pointe des pieds vous
avez entendu tout bas je t'aime vous lui
avez dit si tu tu même lève-toi et
marche et le lendemain elle galopait
dans l'appartement c'est vrai je me suis
pris pour le Christ euh oui c'est vrai
c'est vrai ça s passé comme ça c'est
vrai c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est vrai
oui il y a il y a des moments où la la
réalité euh a plus de talent que que la
fiction et votre mère vous êtes donc
réconciliée avant qu'elle ne disparaisse
et ça c'est important céta essentiel
pour vous vers la fin il était il était
il était tard mais elle m'a dit des
choses elle m'a même envoyé une à une
époque pour me dire
que qu'elle était un peu brusque avec
moi parce qu'elle était intimidée et
qu'elle savait pas comment me parler
alors que du coupah du coup elle me
disait des conneries du genre elle vit
me voir au Zénit il y avait 4500
personnes dans la salle elle me disait
après comment fail que les gens ne
t'aiment pas je dis mais quels gens
maman les gens que tu vois change de
fréquentation je sais pas je sais pas
qui tu vois tu tu vois qui tu vois des
flics tu vois quoi tu vois le les
renseignements
généraux il y avait 4000 personnes qui
m'applaudissaient debout ça va ça va ça
va je suis je suis rassuré je t'assure
non elle avait vraiment un problème de
relation avec moi mais vers la fin où
elle a elle a elle s'est démaquillée si
j'ose dire on s'entendait très bien et
vous avez regretté guide toutes ces
années passées ou pas oh bah quel gâie
c'est ce que vous es dit c'est pas parce
que ça a été la femme de ma vie pendant
longtemps même dans les moments où je la
critiqua où je faisais rire d'elle sur
scène ça ça voulais dire je t'aime quand
même elle l'a compris ça oui je crois
ou je crois puis éta assez fire je parle
d'elle ça j'imagine Jo votre épouse elle
dit que vous n'exercez aucune autorité
vis-à-vis de vos enfants d'ailleurs ils
en témoignent l'un et l'autre
Victoria Nicolas aucune autorité de la
tende je tellement
être le père que je n'ai pas eu j'ai dit
d'ailleurs de moi que j'étais un père
goil avec des réflexes de mère juive
donc toujours très protecteur vis-à-vis
de vos enfants oui non parce que voilà
bah tiens exemple réalité fiction si
j'avais pas été le père de ces enfant là
j'aurais jamais pu faire ce personnage
là qui n'est pas moi non plus je le fais
exprès c'est du théâtre je me suis fait
une tête de vieux pour pour pour jouer
de mon fils justement mais est-ce que
vous aimeriez de venir justement d'aller
jusqu 95 parce que je assure que c'est
pas c'est pas TRC d'amour hein
franchement ça me plaît pas mais vous
pensez vraiment comme le général de
Gaulle puisque vous le rappelez aussi
dans votre livre que la vieillesse est
un naufrage la vraie vieillesse oui oui
oui si on vieillit en pleine forme gu en
pleine forme mais quand on perd son
autonomie quand on est obligé de
demander tout à tout le monde et cetera
quand on est sous tutelle enfin bref
toutes les toutes les vaches on a
inventé pour humilier les vieux que vaut
cette vie que vaut cette vie ça sert à
quoi de
vivre c'est vrai que c'est la qualité de
la vie qui est important la liberté de
mourir dans la dignité mais la liberté
de vivre dans la dignité c'est très
important aussi c'est c'est
lié tout ça mais vous êtes militant gu
pour le droit de mourir dans la
dignitéincr j'ai pas de carte Mo jamais
de carte je me méfie des cartes
mais vous faites partie de ceux qui se
battent pour que la loi change ah oui ça
en tout cas oui pour rester maître de
son dé c'est extraordinaire que Madame
SBIR a demandé la permission bon elle
avait envie de populariser la cause mais
dans les mêmes temps bon et je parle pas
mal d'elle parce que c'était très
émouvant cette histoire et j'en parle
dans le livre etand dis que et quand je
dis que ça m'a fait pleurer ça m'a fait
pleurer peut-être rappeler juste au
téléspectateurs c'est cette femme qui
qui a eu ce cancer terrible oui terrible
je crois du cerveau ou plutôt des sinus
parce qu'elle dit à un moment elle dit à
quoi ça sert un corps à vivre agir à
baiser et cetera bon ben et puis on la
voit en gros plan on comprend bien que
que voilà ça va elle a décidé elle c'est
son droit c'est son droit c'est notre
droit à tous nen déplaise à aux gens qui
sont bloqué par la religion par ceci
cela je les respecte ils ont le droit de
se livrer à l'acharnement thérapeutique
qui a lieu encore dans certains
établissements et j'ai aidé moi pas
personnellement j'ai pas fait une
piqûure j'ai pas donné une potion
mais plusieurs de mes amis sont partis
aidés par des médecins amis et et qui
étaient des bienfaiteurs parce que d'une
certaine manière la souffrance physique
et et morale
qui qui Pr c'est de la mort est bien
pire que la mort c'est vrai que vous
avez perdu beaucoup de personnes aour a
temps euh voilà j'ai perdu des gens que
j'adorais et que que je trimbale avec
moi dans ma dans ma poitrine ma poitrine
est un cimetière il y a Simone Coré il y
a pierre desprog et puis il y a des
anonymes et puis il y a des femmes que
j'ai épousé ma première femme c'est pas
un secret s'est suicidé elle a choisi
elle de mourir dans la dignité c'est
elle qui a décidé
besoin besoin de faire un bilan Guy
quand même malgré tout vous à travers ce
livre parce que c'est un peu prématuré
pour faire un testament mais moi je vais
bien qu'on se rassure ou qu'on s'en
offusque mais je vais bien qui pourrait
s'en offusquer dit-toi ne m'enlevez pas
mes ennemis je les ai mérité je
rencontre beaucoup plus d'amis que
d'ennemis hein en tout cas c'est une
façon d'exorciser aussi parce qu'en fait
moi je suis là à plaider pour pour le
droit de mourir dans la dignité et d'une
certaine manière moi je voudrais
l'éternité normal bah oui non parce que
en une fois quand je le dis quand je
l'écris par amour de la vie mais de la
vraie vie une vie qui se prouve une vie
qui
sert et qui sert aux autres aussi une
vie de combat engagé comme vous avez
toujours été citoyen c'est vrai quand je
lis la presse et die sais que je la lis
et cetera et que je vois ce qu'on est en
train de faire à la planète avec ces
menaces de guerre c'est là maintenant
voilà dans la la récession ça tous les
mensonges toutes les injustices et tout
ça bien sûr il faudrait que les cons
arrive à quand même à comprendre que on
a beau être à l'abri du pire on peut
s'intéresser aux autres aussi ça peut
arriver non quand je vois des gens qui
sont des chrétiens militants et cetera
et qui qui qui font le dans le celui-là
bobo gauche caviier connard bref allez
m'énerve de toute façon vous répondez
gauche couscous c'est ça j'ai bien
compris bah oui mais parce que je suis
très engagé dans le combat pour les sans
papierers pour ça voilà je trouve qu'on
a et alors là pour le coup ma vie à moi
est un échec total car je ça fait des
années que je radote sur le racisme sur
les injustices sociales sur tout ça et
ça n'a jamais était aussi
indécent que ces temps-ci c'est une
horreur donc vous avez l'impression
d'être de n'avoir servi à rien je sers à
je sers à à faire du bien aux gens qui
viennent me voir parce que j'ai fait
justement du drôle avec du triste parce
que je les ai fait un petit peu
réfléchir que je leur ai donné envie de
se battre aussi que je les console et
que je les venge voilà ça sert à ça j'ai
décidé de me donner tous les
Dr vous aviez tous les droits ce so sauf
de blesser des innocents ce que vous
n'avez pas toujours
respecté j'ai j'ai dérapé parfois oui
mais sinon je fais en sorte de ne
m'attaquer qu'à des cibles importantes
dangereuse et qui ont largement les
moyens de se défendre ça c'est l'âge
peut-être et je vous
emmerde VI
merci qu'est-ce que vous avez dit ma
vieille merci merci beaucoup
gu pour ne rien manquer sur ma chaîne
Inna Mireille Duma abonnez-vous et
activez la
[Musique]
cloche